two weeks ago the state of california
sued activision blizzard one of the
biggest gaming publishers in the world
for allegedly breaking the law by
discriminating against women and
creating an environment where women were
constantly sexually harassed at work
in the days since there have been a ton
of responses to this news from blizzard
employees walking out on the job in
protest
to blizzard's president leaving the
company so let's break down everything
that happened in the last week
[Music]
so if you're here you probably already
know what happened the last few weeks
but in case you didn't the state of
california is suing activision blizzard
for creating what the lawsuit alleges
was
frat house culture of the company
basically the lawsuit alleges that
activision blizzard leadership allowed
women to be discriminated
against and to be sexually harassed or
assaulted at work
a lot of people weren't exactly happy
with activision blizzard following news
of the lawsuit breaking
last time on the show we talked about
how women who worked at activated
blizzard were coming forward on twitter
with stories about how they had been
assaulted or harassed while working at
the company
and about how fans were doing things
like cancelling wow subscriptions on
mass
but the protests got a lot bigger and
then earlier this week
blizzard president j alan brack left the
company after
thousands of employees signed a letter
calling activision blizzard's response
to the lawsuit abhorrent and insulting
they scheduled a walkout
now to be clear this wasn't a strike the
difference being that while the activist
employees did have demands
what they weren't saying is that they
wouldn't go back to work unless those
demands were
met and to be clear as of filming those
demands have not been met
at least not publicly on july 27th the
activision blizzard walkout for equality
saw
dozens of people walk out on blizzard's
campus in california
their demands were an end to mandatory
arbitration causes and contracts
reforming the hiring and promotion
policies to improve representation at
all levels
publishing data on relative compensation
to ensure fair payment
and to create a company-wide dei task
force that can hire a third party to
audit activision blizzard's hr and
executive staff
plenty of folks in the games industry
showed their support for the workers who
walked out and demonstrated and even
ubisoft employees published a letter in
support of them demanding fair treatment
across the entire industry
as reported by axios reporter stephen
tottillo so on july
28th in response to the walkout
activision blizzard ceo bobby kotick
made a statement in which he promised
things were going to change at the
company but the very next day activision
blizzard hired the law firm wilmer hale
to review their hr policies which as
kotaku's mike fahey pointed out
was most recently in the news for their
work trying to prevent amazon employees
from unionizing
now while it is pretty common to have an
outside firm review hr policies when you
have a situation like this
a lot of people saw this move as a slap
in the face to concerned employees both
because of wilmer hale's history of
union busting
and also because the employees weren't
consulted about this hiring at all
to be clear a move like this can be made
with the best of intentions
but when the party being sued is hiring
lawyers for mediation and review
without consulting the people who wanted
that mediation review
you can see how it looks pretty [ __ ]
bad on august 3rd activision blizzard
employees who have organized calling
themselves the abk workers alliance sent
out another letter in response to both
codex comments and to the hiring of
wilmer hale
the letter states that activision
blizzard employees didn't find that
kodik's response addressed their
concerns
it also says that the hiring of loma
hale is both a conflict of interest and
doesn't represent the employee's best
interests
in response to our demands you wrote a
letter to employees expressing a
commitment to doing a better job of
listening
you said you would do everything
possible to work with employees in
improving our workplace
and yet the solutions you proposed in
that letter did not meaningfully address
our requests
you ignored our call for an end to
mandatory arbitration you did not commit
to adopting inclusive recruitment and
hiring practices
you made no comment on pay transparency
essentially activision blizzard
employees feel that not only is the
company not listening to their demands
they're
actively working against them and then
just a few hours after that letter was
published blizzard president j
alan brack stepped down from his role at
the company brack is being replaced by
jen o'neill and mike ibarra who will be
the co-heads of blizzard going forward
in a statement brac said i am confident
that jen o'neil and mike ibarra will
provide the leadership blizzard needs to
realize its full potential
and will accelerate the pace of change i
anticipate they will do so with passion
and enthusiasm and that they can be
trusted to lead with the highest level
of integrity and commitment to the
components of our culture that make
blizzard so special
brac leaving is a huge deal he was with
the company for a long time since 2005
and has been president since mike
morheim left in 2018
but many have criticized brac's
departure by suggesting that it's
something of a smokescreen
while brac may or may not have been
directly responsible for the culture of
harassment and discrimination at the
company
activision blizzard employees never
asked for his or anyone else's
resignation
all they wanted was more transparency
and a seat at the table when it came to
discussing inclusion and safety in the
workplace but brac was not the only
person who left blizzard this week
on august 3rd bloomberg's jason schreier
reported that jesse messchuck blizzard's
senior people officer and top hr rep
left the company as well
this departure wasn't seen as terribly
surprising given the allegations in the
lawsuit that hr wasn't trusted within
the company and a follow-up report from
axios's meghan faraok manesh about how
hr would defend known abusers and did
not keep reports confidential
farooqkamesh's report was far from the
only one to come out following the
lawsuit there has been a lot of
reporting in the last couple of days
that are uncovering some pretty
disturbing stories from activision
blizzard
vice's lorenzo francischi bcri reported
on the time a blizzard employee at a
recruiting conference asked a woman
about the last time she was penetrated
and kotaku's ethan gatch reported on the
truth behind the cosby suite
a hotel room used by blizzard employees
during blizzcon to drink a network which
featured a literal photo of bill cosby
as photos posted by former blizzard
employees
and obtained by kotaku show the lawsuit
alleges that the cosby suite was former
wow senior creative director alex of
frasier's room at blizzcon
and since he was allegedly a known
abuser and harasser
his room was nicknamed the cosby suite
after alleged rapist bill cosby
since kotaku's report came out former
blizzard developer and kurt ryan
employee greg street has alleged that
the cosby suite was a break room and
that was nicknamed as such because of an
inside joke
and that he is now embarrassed by the
nickname kotaku also reported that
activision blizzard's executive vice
president and former george w bush
administration member fran townsend
went on a twitter blocking spree after
she was criticized for insensitive
comments following the lawsuit deceros
theo salon reported that t-mobile has
seemingly pulled out of their overwatch
league and call of duty league
sponsorships
while neither t-mobile or blizzard made
any statements it's not hard to imagine
that this could have been a result of
the lawsuit
then on august 3rd activision blizzard
had their quarterly investor relations
call which was criticized by basically
everybody listening as being
extraordinarily tone deaf as it focused
more on upcoming game launches than
addressing any of these alleged issues
at the company
and finally also on august 3 activision
blizzard shareholders filed a class
action lawsuit against activision
blizzard
for not disclosing information about
harassment complaints at the company and
investigations into the company with
regards to discrimination
of course don't get too excited about
the shareholders coming to save the day
they mostly only care about the money as
rs technica's kyle orland points out the
shareholders are concerned because
withholding this info led to a quote
artificially inflated share price
basically activision blizzard stock
dropped from 90
to 84 on the day the news of the lawsuit
broke and has dropped as low as 79
in the day since so activision blizzard
shareholders feel like they're entitled
to damages because they think the
company lied to them about how stable
the company was
which brings us to today because this
story is far from over
activision blizzard employees demands
have still not been met activision
blizzard is hiring a union-busting law
firm to run damage control
and now we have two lawsuits to settle
but here
while we have a lull in the action i
want to take a moment to say that the
mountain of allegations about the
culture at activision blizzard and the
behavior of the staff of the company is
overwhelming i'd like to think that it's
not controversial to say that nobody
should ever be made to feel unsafe at
work
and that nobody should ever be paid less
because of their gender or the color of
their skin
my point is that the activision blizzard
employee's demands are
reasonable and i really do hope
activision blizzard listens because
i want to see some real reform in the
games industry unfortunately given
activision blizzard's response over the
last week i find that really unlikely
instead i think this story is just gonna
keep going at least until activision
blizzard loses a lawsuit or has to pay
out the victims
[Music]
you